it's the actual thing that separates men
from the boys and this week this week
there is going to be an unusual
timekeeping event in leap second is
coming every few years an extra second
is added to account for a mismatch
between clocks in the Earth's rotation
that's right this Tuesday night there is
going to be a leap second just before
midnight coordinated Universal Time the
clock will go from 11:59 fifty nine to
eleven fifty nine sixty which sounds
less like an actual time and more like
how a pufferfish describes his ideal
woman oh she's a perfect eleven fifty
nine sixty real narrow round and then
even rounder look I know an extra second
does not seem like that big a deal but
you can get a lot done in a second you
can spoil the twist endings of classic
movies I'll show you dudes dead
so say you Spacey kitchen remodel still
in progress but very much on track the
pot the push sticks the point is we want
you to enjoy your extra second on
Tuesday so we've purchased spend your
leap second here dot-com and uploaded
some of the greatest one second videos
you could possibly imagine
now let me give you a quick taster here
is an upside-down sloth making a weird
sound a great second you just spent that
second very well I'll give you another
here is Mariah Carey's dog into a fight
with Mariah Carey's cat during the
taping of Mariah Carey's cribs episode
that's arguably a more important second
conduct Big Bang was so pleased on
Tuesday go to spend your leap second
picket calm or indeed to John Oliver sex
tapes calm which yes we bought before we
set it out loud and you can enjoy such
magnificent micro-moments
as Bobby Cannavale a arctic acting the
out of the words leap second leap
second Bravo Bravo Bobby if you're
thinking for hold on if we all go to
that website at the same time on Tuesday
won't it crash that seems unlikely
nothing like that has ever famously
happened before so go to John Oliver sex
tapes calm and waste your extra second
with us that's our show we're off next
week we'll be back after that thank you
so much good night